the Joe Rogan experience it's so great I
was talking to a guy who used to be in
charge at Viacom and we were talking
about you know when they when people do
shows now like you know they'll pay
Kenny Berra so the patient arrived at
little pay Dave Allen Chris all these
guys like 20 million the writers get a
hundred buddy mind Mike Schur created
good place and Parks and Rec and he's
getting twenty five mil a year for the
next five years yes it's his heart his
shows are picked up and successful but
they're not like cheers right and I said
to Doug her I like the guy from [ __ ] I
go how much were you [ __ ] guys making
before what were these what were these
companies making twenty years ago like
what was ABC making twenty years ago
that they and they even Seinfeld said
that he's like I was the first one to
get a hundred million in episode and I
go which is a pittance compared to what
they could have paid and he's like I
know that now but back then a million
dollars in uh what are you even gonna
deal with it and now it's like what are
they gonna do with it what the [ __ ] they
were making they were making a hundred
million in episode but because it's a
logo and a corporation go well that's
what a corporation's supposed to make
one hundred million dollars an episode
meanwhile if a guy makes a million
you're like what are you gonna it's like
this unfathomable thing it's like where
they get mad at basketball players and
not the owners of the teams yeah and
it's also that distribution model of
like putting something on a network it's
there's so much fat there's so many
people there's so many things that you
have to pay yes so much so many
different places the money goes it's
almost like you have to make a hundred
million dollars in episode for everybody
to make out yeah but also another don't
live but also they're still taking
ninety the Uniting
even with all the revenues with all like
the the the all the miles I got a fade
it's still like a huge profit but as a
writer don't you think of like investing
your time and effort into a sitcom today
good luck with that I don't dude I like
I just started to I we used to the
podcast me motion to this podcast call
the champs it was great and and now I
just started one like a month ago called
how neo failed look for it and you're
look thanks how he'll handle feel that's
the name of the party got a theme song
everything's very sick but it was I was
like why am i trying I did a pilot like
a year ago for a network and they gave
me notes and I was like oh I forgot
about notes
I forgot that they were gonna give me
notes like uh like I don't just let me
that was the other thing that me and
Dave got to with Comedy Central and they
finally left us alone after like six
episodes where I was like let us show it
to the audience and let them just we
don't want to bomb we want to bomb less
than you guys do trust me trust me
you've never met two people who want a
bomb less than me and him and so they'd
be like well we don't really let's show
to the crowd if they like it then great
and if they don't then and we did we did
this real world sketch and they didn't
they were like we just think it's a
bunch of unfunny scenes back-to-back and
we're like let's just show to the crowd
and then we showed it killed and they
were like all right we don't know we're
talking about they literally said we
don't know we're talking about so do
whatever you want unfunny what a [ __ ]
oh those feed but but that's the I get
that they feel like they have to do
something
yeah but we're what comedians are
willing to like all our skins in the
game it's all it's all of our it's our
hide every time so why do you feel the
need to like correct us or I don't mind
if it if like a executive is like the
first audience do you know domain are
like a your shirts [ __ ] at whatever
like like a minor stuff but it's like
materialized most of you are not good at
divining what's special about somebody
or what's an innovative segment or you
know I mean like they'd only think about
that they're just they're ambitious
people who are just like working the way
up a thing and they're like is it my
turn yet right I get to [ __ ] I get to
put my stamp on it now yeah
want to add something even if it's
irrelevant like me I had a joke when we
were doing half-baked and going to
fertility but uh we're doing half-baked
and I said to Dave ago we should do a
thing at the end where we should just
say hey let us do whatever we want and
at the end we'll pass a hat around and
you guys can take credit for something
because ultimately that's what you want
you want to be able to take credit for
something right
don't [ __ ] make us do it I know you
just want credit that's all you want you
just want to feel good about yourself
you want to feel like I contributed to
this thing but let us just let us do the
thing United man and if you're like you
would just been howling been doing the
podcast almost ten years yeah
maybe ten years in December you're gonna
do a big Network show about okay
networking about taking over an AM radio
station for the day that's so funny
it'll be really funny the wonder if
they'd let me
[Applause]